frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger die bilder aus der ukraine
sind kaum zu ertragen
tausende fliehen wahrscheinlich jeder
hier im saal hat eine nachricht bekommen
von freunden bekannten von kolleginnen
und kollegen mit dem man so wie ich
letzte woche noch gemeinsam in kiew
mittag gegessen hat die jetzt sagen
'bitte rettet uns eltern mit kleinen
kindern verbringen in u-bahn-schächten
ihre nächte um schutz vor bomben und
raketen zu suchen das könnten wir in
diesem bahn schächten sein dass könnten
unsere kinder sein was wir gerade mitten
in europa passiert war für jemand aus
meiner generation bisher unvorstellbar
es ist der moment in dem der
angriffskrieg nach europa zurück
gekommen ist
unsere welt ist nach diesem
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg von
putin jetzt eine andere
botschaft wenig ich begrüße sie hier im
saal
stellvertretend für die über 40
millionen mutigen ukrainerin und ukraine
ich möchte ihnen hier aus ganzem herzen
sagen das unsägliche leid der männer
frauen und kinder trifft uns ins mark
wir sind fassungslos angesichts dessen
was der ukraine was den menschen in der
ukraine erneut angetan wird aber wir
sind nicht ohnmächtig wir lassen sie in
dieser rücksichtslosen aggression auf
gelangt nicht alleine
dieser krieg ist kein krieg der menschen
in russland
dieser krieg ist putins krieg
dieser krieg ist ein angriff auf unseren
frieden in europa dieser krieg ist ein
angriff auf unsere freiheit dieser krieg
ist ein angriff auf das internationale
völkerrecht dieser krieg ist ein angriff
auf all die werte einer regelbasierten
internationalen ordnung und dieser krieg
ist ein angriff auf das menschliche
friedliche miteinander
und es ist ein krieg der es nötig macht
dass wir die grundfesten unseres
außenpolitischen handelns 19 vor wenigen
wochen noch habe ich hier in diesem saal
zum thema waffenlieferungen gesagt dass
man seine außenpolitische
180 grad wendung im richtigen moment und
bei vollem bewusstsein treffen muss
jetzt ist so traurig es ist der moment
dafür wir haben es bis zuletzt zur
letzten minute mit diplomatie versucht
der kreml hat uns hingehalten belogen
und sich all dem verweigert wofür wir
bisher als europäerinnen und europäer
eingestanden haben putin wollte diesen
krieg whatever it takes
russland hat die ukraine rücksichtslos
angegriffen und die ukraine hat wie
jedes land dieser welt ein recht auf
selbstverteidigung verbrieft in der tat
hat der verein fraktion
und wir die auf dem boden das
völkerrecht stehen stehen auch in der
pflicht diese charta der vereinten
nationen jetzt gemeinsam zu verteidigen
vielleicht ist es so
dass deutschland am heutigen tag eine
form besonderer und alleinstehender
zurückhaltung in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik hinter sich zuletzt
die regeln die die uns dafür gegeben
haben dürfen uns nicht aus unserer
verantwortung nehmen wenn uns gewählt
ein andere ist dann muss auch unsere
politik eine andere sein
ein land mit einer parlamentsarmee und
umfassender demokratischer kontrolle
darf und muss sich erlauben und das tun
wir mit dem heutigen tag in fragen von
krieg und frieden in voller
verantwortung zu entscheiden
wir werden bei waffenexporten und
einsetzen weiter aus tiefster
überzeugung zurückhaltend sein wir
werden uns aber in dieser historischen
stunde
angesichts des brutalen angriffs auf die
ukraine für eine unterstützung
entscheiden die neben unserem großen
wirtschaftlichen und humanitären
engagement die ukraine jetzt auch mit
lieferung von militärischen material und
waffen unterstützt
weil wir dürfen die ukraine nicht
wehrlos dem aggressor überlassen der tod
und verwüstung über dieses land bringt
und ich danke ihnen alle sehr wie auch
der bundeskanzler das ist die stärke
dieses wohnhauses das ist die stärke
unserer liberalen demokratien dass ihr
bei sachfragen streiten können erbittert
aber dass wir in dem moment wo es darum
geht unsere grundwerte zu verteidigen
alle
fraktionsübergreifend beieinander stehen
herzlichen dank
wir tun das außenministerin annalena
baerbock
sie spricht gerade noch weiter wären
direkt noch einmal steht wir tun dies
mit besonnenheit und aus verantwortung
um unseren frieden in europa und das ist
auch eine klare botschaft an wladimir
putin das preisschild dieses krieges
gegen unschuldige menschen oder bruch
mit der charta der vereinten nationen
wird für das system putin und tragbar
seien
wir müssen und das hat der bundeskanzler
unterstrichen jetzt vieles gleichzeitig
tun wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
menschen in der ukraine schnell mit dem
nötigsten versorgt werden mit
medizinischen gütern mit sicheren
unterkünften
dafür haben wir unter anderem unseren
beitrag zum humanitären vn hilfsfonds
für die ukraine um 5 millionen
aufgestockt wir stellen für das
internationale komitee des roten kreuzes
weitere hilfe in höhe von zehn millionen
euro kurzfristig bereit wir werden uns
mit allem was wir da haben gemeinsam
dafür einsetzen dass die menschen die
jetzt liegen alle alle in sicherheit
kommen und dafür haben wir
vorbereitungen getroffen und auch das
ist unsere stärke nicht nur in der
europäischen union sondern gemeinsam mit
unseren freunden in kanada in amerika
und an vielen vielen anderen orten in
der welt wir lassen die fliegen den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer nicht im
stich
und ja auch an dieser stelle müssen wir
über geld reden und ich bitte um die
unterstützung im vorausschauenden
haushalt eben diese humanitäre hilfe
dann auch so auszustatten wie wir das
für den schutz der menschen brauchen
drei weitere elemente sind entscheidend
erstens sanktionen und die bittere
realität ist keine sanktion kann diesen
wahn in diesem moment stoppen wir hätten
wenn wir ein sanktionsmittel hätte dass
alle stopp natürlich dieses längst
ergriffen aber was unsere sanktionen
leisten und das ist zentral ist putin zu
zeigen mittel und langfristig wird
dieser krieg ihr land ruinieren putins
perfides spiel ist auf strecke angelegt
deswegen müssen das auf unsere
sanktionen seien und deswegen müssen wir
so sicherstellen dass uns nicht nach
drei monaten die puste ausgeht sondern
diese sanktionen müssen das system putin
im kern treffen deswegen
deswegen gehen sie hand in hand
wirtschaftlich finanziell und
individuell deswegen listen wir herrn
putin selbst und den außenminister
lawrow sie tragen verantwortung für
diesen krieg und deswegen werden wir
weitere sanktionen auf den weg bringt
mit blick auf banken oligarchen und
familienangehörige und deswegen haben
wir swift und ich kann verstehen dass da
einige etwas nervös geworden sind aber
ich bitte in diesen zeiten um vertrauen
deswegen haben wir es wirft so angelegt
dass sie das system putin treffen und
nicht als bumerang auf uns zurück kommen
und das gemeinsam mit der
internationalen verantwortung die wir
jetzt gemeinsam
wir unterstützen unsere bündnispartner
im namen der rat nato das hat der
bundeskanzler bereits deutlich gemacht
die nato ist der garant für unsere
sicherheit und freiheit dafür wurde sie
gegründet und daran hat sich nichts
verändert
und mein letzter punkt ja wir müssen
härte zeigen aber wir stehen hier fühlt
das internationale recht und tina zu
internationalen regeln ein deswegen
gehört in diesem moment der dialog immer
mit dazu nicht mit dem aggressor sondern
mit der internationalen gemeinschaft das
muss jetzt unser absoluter fokus sein es
geht hier nicht nur um europa kein land
der welt kann akzeptieren dass seine
souveränität zur disposition steht wenn
sein stärkerer nachbar es will
dann hätte putin gewonnen deswegen
müssen wir uns jetzt gemeinsam mit allen
staaten die wie wir an die charta der
vereinten nationen glauben dieser
aggression entgegen stellen deswegen
appelliere ich auch hier an all unsere
partner weltweit hier aus diesem
geschichtsträchtigen hohen haus bekennen
sie nächste woche farbe in der
generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen
das ist unsere internationale
friedensordnung wir müssen sie jetzt
gemeinsam verteidigen
bei der wahl zwischen krieg und frieden
bei der wahl zwischen einem aggressor
und kindern auf der anderen seite die
sich in u bahn schächten verstecken da
kann niemand neutral sein danke dass wir
das heute hier gemeinsam deutlich machen
der bundesaußenminister in annalena
baerbock gesagt da kann deutschland
nicht neutral sein die nur 180 grad
wende bekannt gibt so hat sie es benannt
und eine grüne bundes außenministerin
die eine massive aufrüstung gerade und
waffenlieferungen in das kriegsgebiet
verkündet erklärt claus strunz also das
aufsehen erregend aber es war auch
gleichzeitig die schwächste rede die wir
bisher gehört haben und die unehrlich
sste weil natürlich sind genau die
grünen gewesen die immer diesen
friedenskurs nach von diesen naiven
friedenskurs nach vorn gestellt haben
natürlich ist es annalena baerbock
gewesen die bei ihrem besuch in kiew
unlängst noch jede waffen jeden gedanken
an waffenlieferungen ab kategorisch
abgelehnt hat sie hat die persönliche
180 grad drehung dahin gelegt und es
wäre ihr zur ehre gereicht hätte sie das
heute einmal erwähnt dass gedanken die
früher als richtig erschienen als falsch
entlarvt sind und man sich jetzt eben
anders ende das hätte ich erwartet denn
eigentlich macht annalena baerbock ja in
den letzten tagen guten job ein gedanke
noch der mir gerade durch den kopf ging
es ist schon irgendwie eine ironie der
geschichte dass es immer rot grüne
regierungen sind die krieg führen müssen
denn als 98 schröder an die macht kam
der spd kanzler der jetzt so unrühmlich
sozusagen agiert stand kosovo
unmittelbar bevor also immer in letzter
zeit wenn rot grüne regierungen an die
macht kommen dann kommt krieg und sie
müssen damit fertig werden